dead were just hearing from the West
Yorkshire police who are holding a news
conference at the labour Member of
Parliament who was attacked earlier she
was shot twice she was stabbed she has
died after the attack we understand she
was in a critical condition but the West
Yorkshire Police have confirmed that Cox
died as a result of injuries now the
police have also said a man has been
arrested and weapons have been recovered
the news conference is taking place in
wakefield in west yorkshire she was
attacked earlier today in her district
the West Yorkshire Police say they say
it's too early to discuss a motive it's
unclear we heard earlier that this was
linked in any way to the referendum and
the police say they're not looking for
anyone else linked to the attack a man
has been arrested earlier we heard from
various new sources that a 52 mad two
year old man had had been arrested The
Guardian the BBC newspaper the BBC
website said that a homemade homemade
gun was also found at the scene as well
but the very tragic news which has been
confirmed that Joe Cox the Labour MP has
died there was some speculation in the
Guardian newspaper that an eyewitness
said that Cox's attacker had shouted
Britain first now Britain first is the
name of a group who campaigns against
immigration and Britain's membership of
the United Kingdom just to stay very
clearly Britain first has come out and
said they had absolutely nothing to do
with the attack and I should also say
that both the remain camps and the leave
camps have suspended campaigning in
light of the events that was before we
heard that joe cox had died just some
background Scarlett and Oliver on Joe
[ __ ] she just been a member of
parliament for a year she was 41 year
old 41 years old she was a mother of two
she was an MP for a Yorkshire
constituency court called batley and
spin she'd been an MP as I said since
2015 and she was an ardent supporter of
the EU some further background she was
nominated as a young global leader by
the world economic forum in 2009 I mean
this is a very rare occurrence not only
for an MP to be attacked before a gonna
tag to take place here on UK soil the
last MP to die through a sheet through
an attack was Ian Gao who was killed by
an IRA bomb in 1990 in 2010 and MP was
stabbed he made a full full recovery but
this is a rarity and it's it's a very
sad day and it's a very tragic J day the
police news conference in West Yorkshire
is still taking place but the the big
news here and the devastating news here
for joe cox for her family for the
labour party for her constituency is
that the Labour Party member joe cox has
died after this attack the news
reporting that she was shot twice she
was stabbed away and a man has been
arrested